hey everyone how's it going my name's my
Yuko and in this video we're gonna be
learning about a technology in under two
minutes this is part of a series where I
introduce concepts explain things in an
easy-to-understand way and give you the
foundation that you need to dive deeper
on your own
this is Tekken 2 the topic for today is
back in development so let's start that
timer so in order to talk about back in
development let's revisit what front-end
development is it's the practice of
creating user interfaces that are
flexible and make it easy for a user to
interact with data back in development
is a practice of creating those plugs
into the data oftentimes called an
application program interface or API I
honestly like to think of the backend as
like a panel of plugs where each plug
returns a massage subset of the data and
the panel itself hides away all the
complexity fetching from and updating to
the database
unlike front-end development back-end
isn't specific to any one platform in
fact it serves as more like a foundation
that supports whatever platform sit on
top of it
so to illustrate this let's go back to
our ATM analogy so when a user wants to
withdraw $40 from their account
let's help on various buttons on the
machine or our UI in this case that then
communicates to the backend to actually
carry out those tasks now let's go back
to the panel of plugs visualization
imagine the front-end plugged into one
plug called get money that ploy actually
connects to several other plugs on the
wall to do the business logic for
instance one to check that the user
actually has $40 in their account and
the other to subtract that amount from
their balance developing each of those
plugs is back-end development to make
sure that the user interacts with the
data safely so what's in this deck well
usually it involves two types of
languages one is a server-side
programming language that helps build
the API itself commonly used are Python
Java Ruby PHP and job
script and the second is a sequel
language to actually fetch the data from
the database and what are the important
factors and skills for working in
back-end development one is to have the
architectural skills for making
well-organized extensible and testable
code a big part of back-end is
organizing logic and data so those
skills allow for writing code with speed
and quality and the second is to
communicate clearly with front-end
developers there's a myth that back-end
developers don't need to know anything
about users which is wrong by the way
back-end developers are a big part of
allowing users do what they need to do
to get done so it's a joint effort
between front-end developers and
back-end developers to write code to do
just this and that is back-end
development and that's it for this
episode of tech into the next episode is
something that I know a lot about which
is mobile development and so make sure
to hit that subscribe button so you
don't miss out comment down below any
topics you'd like to see explained in 2
minutes and I will see you next time bye